this is absolutely the best I hope you
enjoy this so yesterday there was a
protest or a rally in lower Manhattan
near where presumably Donald Trump would
be arrested and booked if indeed that
happens right side broadcasting was
covering it live we covered it live and
it was just a complete and total mess
barely anybody showed up there seemed to
be more media than there were actual
protesters it was wild right side
broadcasting is doing interviews and
while of right side broadcasting is
interviewing a young guy draped in some
kind of flag wearing a red Maga hat
Jason from the good liars which is this
satirical left-wing comedy duo they've
done really really good stuff in the
past
slowly Jason from the good Liars who if
you're watching right now you see is
sort of like screen right Jason drifts
into the shot
and the kid who's being interviewed
immediately recognizes Jason and says oh
the good liars the interviewer from
right side broadcasting apparently
doesn't know what the good liars is who
they are doesn't recognize Jason and
Jason just brutally trolls that the
protest was totally flaccid and I know
that technically it the word is
pronounced flaccid but nobody says it
that way so I'm going to continue saying
flaccid so people know it was like a wet
noodle protest totally pathetic Jason
slips in and it's just you have to see
the execution here let's take a look
demeanors entering some misdemeanors to
felonies and a specifically Prosecuting
Donald Trump when he didn't he did very
little wrong if anything he's
Prosecuting much around the city right
now I mean there's crime everywhere hey
good liars what's us so the kid
immediately recognizes him and says hey
the good liar is what's up
and Jason just tries to shake his hand
and keep going the interviewer has no
clue what's going on and this this is
just so well done
there's crime everywhere and I'm think
like this is a political prosecution it
it has to be right like that's that's
the only way
it could be happening right now is that
they're going after a political
politically the only other option is
that Donald Trump lost by seven million
votes and is a loser who can't deal with
the fact that he he lost the election
because he based his whole personality
on being a winner and calling people
losers uh so so as you think his
attitude his approach his personality is
what is is what got us in this mess in
the first place potentially or I'm just
gonna choose to believe that the
election was stolen and everything that
he says the interviewer has no idea
what's going on because I kind of like
first based my whole personality on
supporting Donald Trump so I'm not gonna
maybe accept the option you live in you
live in the city I live in the city yeah
so how's the city changed over the last
couple years here I mean I know crime
but I don't live here so I don't I can't
judge whether it goes it's gone up or
down yeah the New York City I think is
maybe 59th in in crime right now I think
there's four cities in Indiana that has
have more crime statistically than and
the kid next to Jason who's really a
Maga guy knows exactly what's going on
but he's allowing this to continue which
is just amazing work does yeah exactly
so I haven't really noticed a lot of
crime but I do see it on on you know Fox
News they say it's it's much more
dangerous now I don't I haven't seen it
I haven't seen any more crime so like
maybe that's it might not be true but I
I'm gonna choose to believe that it is
true because I I did see that on Fox
news of course because where have you
seen on Fox News is true right yeah just
like CNN and MSNBC if you see it on if
you see it on cable news it's got to be
true Donald Trump says CNN and MSNBC are
fake news okay that's right we got to
use the Frank news okay yep okay so and
then just one more clip here and this is
just so brilliant event
um he's asked to weigh in about like the
size of the of the rally and he he also
slips in some good stuff here so I mean
what's your take on it so far I mean
there's a lot of people out here yeah it
seems like there's a lot of media
um I would say just it's basically all
media and I guess there's uh is it
Braxton there's Braxton and then I see
another guy with the foot it seems like
there's about 10 Trump supporters here
but mostly there are media yeah so oh
man this is just absolutely fantastic
and uh you know the other the other
really funny thing in general about this
is that the Trump sort of like asked
supporters to be ready to protest or
whatever the case may be they're not
seeming like that willing to do it
interestingly enough except a few did go
out front to Trump Tower and I think
it's quite literally five people and a
woman blows a shofar
[Music]
so there are one two three four I guess
five or six people two holding Trump one
signs and one woman blows a shofar and
that's what they were able to sort of
coalesce at Trump Tower this is starting
to become surreal as if it hasn't been
surreal for the last six days it is
unbelievable what is going on here and
that's not even counting what Donald
Trump Jr's last 24 hours look like one
of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipx also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to zipx
toothpicks.com today save 10 with the
code pacman10 at checkout just remember
you must be 21 or older to order the
link is down below